okay big big big announcement today
after the program today I will be going
to Boston's Logan Airport and I will be
flying hopefully non-stop unless there
is a change to the itinerary of my plane
to Los Angeles California because
tomorrow Wednesday I will be appearing
live
I think it's live on the Joe Rogan
program this is extremely exciting have
been trying to put this together with
Joe for a while I was not planning on
taking time off from the show this week
or anytime soon really up until the
fourth of July break because I was just
gone and this came together very quickly
the flights came together very quickly a
June fifth Wednesday June fifth at 3:00
p.m. Eastern noon pacific i will be on
with joe rogan it will be a wide-ranging
and informative conversation I am going
in excited to talk to Joe about what am
i for as a progressive leftist and I
think it is a great opportunity to talk
about what it is that I stand for what
are my views we will talk about media we
will talk about online media culture and
youtubers and censorship and platforming
hopefully and all of this stuff and
probably many other things I have no
idea about as many Joe Rogan
conversations tend to sort of take a
life of their own
so I will be away from the show
Wednesday Thursday and the plan is and I
have such bad luck with flights that I
always say the plan is that I will be
flying back to Boston Thursday and will
be back on the show Friday and we will
do a full regular Friday show with news
stories and audience questions and live
calls and all of that stuff if it
changes I will make sure that Benjamin
Dixon the guest host that we are going
to have in lets you know about that Ben
has very graciously Anne done relatively
short notice agreed to fill in for me on
Wednesday and Thursday while I am away I
will be appearing on some other shows as
well but the main attraction is going to
be appearing with Joe Rogan tomorrow
Wednesday so wish me luck I am sort of
nervous about it's a big audience I want
to make the best possible impression for
what I do and for what my views are but
all like
do is show up and talk to Joe and do the
best I can so that is what's going on
our our membership audience learned
about this on yesterday's bonus show
telling everybody today so that's where
I will be and I'm trying to think if
there's anything else to mention about
this I guess not
I will be oh I have some interesting
lunches and dinners scheduled while in
Los Angeles with some progressive
personalities that many of you will
recognize so follow my instagram david
pakman follow the adventure I'll
probably be posting some pictures from
some of these meetups that I think
you'll find very interesting meetups not
audience meetups but just meeting up
with other los angeles-based
progressive online media personalities